people often ask how can Arabic be
considered a single language when its
dialects are so different from each
other if they only spoke their own
Arabic dialects then I would say there
were several different languages like
magrebi Egyptian levantine and golf Etc
in their informal spoken forms they can
be as different as Spanish Portuguese
and Italian like different but closely
related languages but they all use the
same literary language Modern Standard
Arabic which they can use to make
themselves more easily understandable to
each other they usually don't switch to
MSA completely but adapt their dialects
to sound a little more like MSA and meet
each other halfway it's that literary
language that unites all of the
varieties and makes them mutually
intelligible when people make
adjustments to their own speech English
and other languages are like that to
some extent if a black American who
speaks aave talks to a Scotsman they'll
probably be able to communicate but they
won't speak the way they speak with
their family and friends they'll speak a
little more like a book and choose their
words more carefully